En este video hablaremos sobre una de las formas
más comunes de medir la concentración de solutos
en una solución, y ésa es la molaridad. La
molaridad se define como la cantidad de moles de
soluto, lo que estamos disolviendo en un solvente,
dividido entre los litros de la solución. Así que
hagamos un ejemplo, y veamos si podemos calcular
la molaridad de una solución. Imagina que tenemos
un recipiente como este, y voy a disolver un
poco de sulfato de sodio en agua, entonces el
sulfato de sodio es el soluto y el agua es el
solvente, juntos nos dan la solución. Y digamos
que el volumen total de la solución es igual a
250 mililitros, y esa solución está compuesta de
-sólo para dar un repaso- el solvente que, en este
ejemplo es agua, H₂O, ¿y si decimos que tenemos
250 mililitros de solución eso quiere decir que
tenemos 250 mililitros de agua? La respuesta
sería que no exactamente, ya que el volumen de 250
mililitros lo conforma el agua más el sulfato de
sodio. Entonces vamos a tener un poco de sulfato
de sodio aquí; ahora digamos que tenemos 35.5
gramos de sulfato de sodio -esta es la fórmula del
sulfato de sodio-. Entonces, con esta información,
¿cómo calculamos la molaridad? Bueno, lo primero
que podemos decir es: "Muy bien, conozco la
cantidad de gramos de sulfato de sodio, ahora
necesito calcular la cantidad de moles". Y para
calcular la cantidad de moles tienes que ver la
masa molar, que podrías calcular a partir de una
tabla periódica de los elementos. Pero para que
esto sea un poco más rápido, te ayudaré un poco
aquí. La masa molar del sulfato de sodio es 142.04
g/mol. Entonces, con toda la información que te
he dado, pausa este video y trata de calcular la
molaridad de esta solución. ¿Cuál es la molaridad
del sulfato de sodio en esta solución? Muy
bien, ahora trabajemos juntos en esto. Entonces,
primero queremos averiguar la cantidad de moles
de soluto, y podemos comenzar con la masa de
soluto que tenemos aquí. Tenemos 35.5 gramos de
sulfato de sodio. Y ahora, si queremos calcular
la cantidad de moles, tenemos que multiplicar esto
por algo que cancele los gramos, pues no queremos
gramos por mol, queremos moles por gramo. Así que
podríamos multiplicar esto por cada mol de sulfato
de sodio, Na₂SO₄, y tenemos 142.04 gramos de
sulfato de sodio; y puedes ver que esto se cancela
con eso y nos quedamos con moles de sulfato de
sodio. En un momento sacaremos la calculadora
y dividiremos 35.5 entre 142.04. Y después, para
calcular la molaridad, queremos dividir entre los
litros de la solución, así que aquí arriba tenemos
la fórmula para calcular el número de moles y
luego los litros de solución: 250 mililitros es
lo mismo que 0.250 litros de nuestra solución.
Y ahora podemos usar nuestra calculadora para
averiguar a qué es igual esto: 35.5 ÷ 142.04 es
igual a esto. Y luego dividimos esto entre 0.250,
y luego eso nos da este resultado. Ahora podemos
pensar en cuántas cifras significativas tenemos,
tenemos tres aquí, tenemos uno, dos, tres, cuatro,
cinco aquí; tenemos tres aquí, por lo que yo
diría que tenemos tres cifras significativas.
Así que redondeamos este 9 aquí, y si redondeamos
eso obtenemos 1.00. Si queremos tener tres cifras
significativas, obtendríamos 1.00. Y luego podrías
decir: ¿cuáles son las unidades aquí? Y lo que la
gente normalmente dirá es que esto es 1.00 molar
-esta M mayúscula es la unidad de molaridad-,
pero en realidad se refieren a la cantidad de
moles de soluto por litro de solución. Y ya está.